From the director of Porky's comes to Christmas classic.
You've seen a thousand times by now,
triple dog, dare you. Wait,
is this movie even good? Or do we just like it?
Cause we had the whole thing memorized a Christmas story.
This holiday season, when everyone in your family starts yelling at each other,
put on a Christmas story and entered the warm confines of a nostalgia to duck it
in a film that looks back fondly on the childhood.
The narrator looks back fondly on that makes you look back fondly on watching it
as a kid and returned to the American Midwest and the [inaudible] were listening
to the radio is considered fun. You could still smack a kid around for laugh.
The toys sucked the real great depression,
trying to have fun with a wagon full of raggedy hands. Hey, well I'm heavy here.
Anyone want to send me the [inaudible] meet Ralphie begged before he got hot and
executive produced Ironman follow along on a single-minded quest to acquire a
firearm and fight against America's only form of gun control parents.
No, shoot your eye out as this little boy spends the entire film scheming for a.
Gun. I want an official action. Do you want to join as well? Aaron dreaming.
About a gun and making up Atlanta's threats to justify owning a gun.
Will you come back? You'll be pushing up gates.
Is that what it feels like to be Republican gather round for a film that isn't
really a bound family or generosity or Christmas,
but more about crass,
materialism survival and the universal holiday message of stop
snitchin.
Ready to tell me [inaudible] rough. Do you know where flake is?
Family and a DOE and boys. This one hanging by a thread. Dad's got rage issues.
Mom's in the verge of a nervous breakdown. My.
Mother, I had not had a hot meal for herself in 15 years.
And the little brother is a ball of anxiety and eating disorders held again.
They're my park. Easy.
You just know they're about to shatter faster than a accidentally broken leg
lamp.
You use up all the glue on purpose
bask.
In the warmth of Jean Shepherd's radio voice.
The greatest Christmas gift I had ever received. What would ever receive as.
You revisit his favorite Christmas,
where he got attacked in the streets at a mental breakdown eight.
So God betrayed by his favorite show.
Got kicked in the hand by Santa's finally got what he wanted for Christmas and
immediately shot himself in the face with it.
Oh my God. I shot my eye. Oh.
Dear Lord. If this is the happiest time of his life,
I'd hate to see what happened.
The other years did have to work in a coal mine did grandpa's get him so whip up
some Ovaltine and enjoy a movie that's like old cinematic wallpaper,
it's chipped and faded and we should probably replace it.
But at the same time,
it's comforting and familiar and we'll never get around to trying something new
because sure you can watch out for if you want to laugh out loud,
which also has Peter Billingsley in it or throwing Netflix to see whatever
random word the algorithm decided to pair with Christmas. But you know,
you'll just tune it to TNT or TBS and watch a Christmas story yet again,
stuck in the same loop of conflict and catharsis.
You can never escape from no matter how old you get. Huh?
I guess it is a movie by family.
After all story fudge dread the
player's ball,
flag pole liquor. I love lamb. I hate lad,
Billy Bob Thornton, and you're wiser sign of liver disease.
He should really get that checked out.
Gut focus. I heard you were slapping your soup suckers together.
Tucking some trash about me calling me some names.
That was a me honest. Do you want atomic.
Wedgie? How about a purple nurple when made my famous Indian arm burn. Hey.
Oh, I want to just grab your own again. Why are you hitting yourself?
Why are you getting yourself out? Want me to stop? You better say it. You.
Better say it. Oh God.
A Christmas sketch show. Jerk, Farkas, stupid bully.
You know, setting aside the Ralphie probably wrote a rant about his gun.
The C plus is probably because he misspelled Christmas time.
To go lick a frozen pool heads as little often at a
time. Be sure to drink year over routine.
I wanted official red rider, carbon action. 200 shot range model air, right.